in response to fears of a chocolate
shortage farmers are looking to a high
yielding variety of cocoa tree which was
developed by Ecuadorian agronomist
Homero Castro so this was a bit strange
that we n descendants and then we start
a sentence with which was developed by
Ecuadorian agronomist Homero
Castro because this right by itself this
isn't a sentence this isn't a sentence
by itself this feels like this which is
referring it's giving us more more
explanation of this high yielding
variety of cocoa tree so I definitely
don't want to separate it as a separate
sentence so I'm always I'm going to
change it so I'm gonna scratch out no
change so let's look at this choice
so this says farmers are looking to a
high yielding variety of cocoa tree ,
which was developed by Ecuadorian
agronomist omorrow Castro so this one
feels quite good I would use a comma and
just go straight to the witch so this
one looks right so let's let's look at
the other choices farmers are looking to
a high yielding variety of cocoa tree
and that tree was developed by
Ecuadorian agronomist O'Meara castro
well this is just unnecessarily wordy
we're using the word tree twice so I
don't like that one and then this last
choice is just like the second choice
but instead of a comma we have a
semicolon and the reason why I like a
comma more than a semicolon I imagine I
I view a semicolon as separating two
clauses that can can almost stand on
themselves and in fact sometimes they
can stand on themselves but there's a
semicolon to kind of show that they are
related while a comma is for the most
part separating clauses that can't stand
the first one can stand on by themselves
in response to fears of a chocolate
shortage farmers are looking to a high
yielding variety of cocoa tree that can
stand by itself but the second clause
has trouble standing by itself in fact
it can't stand as a sentence which was
developed by Ecuadorian agronomist Amero
Castro so I feel good about the comma
right over here and you know don't no
need to overcomplicate things if the
simpler tool works